[Applauso]
ma per me non sono mica io il
protagonista di questo top
ladies and gentlemen aule smith news
caballero ok
ecco per tutti quelli in sala che vanno
dai 40 50 anni e sono appassionati di
moto io potrei finire il coc qui perché
questo è un oggetto che parla da solo
per tutti gli altri volevo raccontarvi
qualcosa ecco questo questa questa moto
negli anni 70 è stata l'oggetto del
desiderio di una marea di ragazzini che
se tu avevi caballero alle ragazzine ti
correvano dietro se non ce l'avevi e
dove vi corre dietro ragazzine quindi
questo è il livello a cui eravamo con
questa con questa moto è stato un
modello di tale successo che l'azienda
che lo produce aveva avuto una crescita
impressionante delle vendite tale che al
fine degli anni 70
l'azienda era il terzo gruppo
motociclistico europeo negli anni
ottanta questa azienda sia superato se
stessa ha vinto tutto quello che c'era
da vincere tre campionati mondiali di
trial i campionati nazionali da
fuoristrada qualsiasi categoria entrava
la vince va bene facciamo un attimo un
fermo immagine di questo
entriamo nelle macchine del tempo
riavvolgiamo il nastro e arriviamo negli
anni negli anni 90 ma avete capito e lo
hanno anche detto quindi non si è
sorpresa sono un appassionato di moto
quali e maggior fortuna per un
appassionato di moto che andare a
lavorare per una fabbrica che fa noto è
quello che mi è successo nel 1991 non
era quella fabbrica agli purtroppo era
un'altra sono entrato che faceva 60
milioni di fatturato sono uscito
quindici anni dopo che ne faceva 630
ecofin ac immaginare cosa significa
essere all'interno di un'azienda che
cresce dieci volte è come essere dentro
una lavatrice che non si ferma mai e
cresce e c'è sempre più nome di fare
quello che riesce a fare però diciamo
che con una fiducia nel team con la
voglia di fare ci si riesce ci sono i
momenti di depressione ci sono i momenti
di gioia delirante ecco cosa resta dopo
15 anni di un'esperienza così esaltante
bene sono due cose 1 una grande
esperienza di dominio ha una grande
esperienza
il settore e dall'altra parte e rischi
restano delle amicizie indissolubili ben
al di là del fatto di essere
semplicemente colleghi lasciamo di nuovo
entriamo nella macchina del tempo e
riemergevano da questa macchina del
tempo nel 2014 precisamente nell'aprile
del 2014
uno di questi amici indissolubili
mariano mi telefona e mi dice senti che
ne dici fare una cena a base di asparagi
allora cena asparagi amici sicuramente
una cosa che non si rifiutano e giù a
capofitto a mangiare a sparita certo
punto siamo nel mezzo di questa
rimpatriata tra amici ex colleghi quando
certo punto maria non prende un cono un
po formale dice ragazzi ve lo ricordate
il caballero il caballero bellissimo il
mito non potevi niente le ragazzine
ok stop ok la fabbrica che produce se la
sta passando veramente male sono rimasti
sei dipendenti fanno meno di un milione
di fatturato sono tre anni che sono in
perdita
guardate che io me lo sento ma non sarei
stupito che tra due mesi due settimane
arriva la notizia che poi saltata la
chiudono oppure è stata acquistata dalla
multinazionale che prende il marchio
caballero e lo butta in un cassetto
polveroso assieme a tanti altri marchi a
questo punto c'è passato un brivido
nella schiena
eravamo il tavolo cinque persone con più
di 100 anni di esperienza motociclistica
accumulata sulle spalle
a questo punto vogliamo lasciare che il
destino faccia il suo corso
o vogliamo mettere la nostra firma sul
più grande piano di rilancio
motociclistico europeo
vabbè avete capito cinque minuti dopo
eravamo pancia a terra a creare un piano
piano prevedeva tre pilastri
fondamentali il primo era continuare a
fare quello che già questa fabbrica
faceva quindi migliorare la rete di
vendita e migliorare il prodotto sulle
moto da fuoristrada
il secondo pilastro delle rilancio era
quello di rivitalizzare completamente il
caballero quindi un po l'operazione che
fiat ha fatto quello al cinquecento o
che in bmw ha fatto con la mini quindi
rimanere su un guscio classico e
metterci dentro tanta tecnologia e il
terzo pilastro in questi di questi
periodi non poteva che essere la
mobilità elettrica
cominciando dalle bici elettriche di
fuori da fuoristrada e le montain bike
che era un po il nostro dna
no per poi andare nelle bici a pedalata
assistita cittadine e poi andare nella
vera mobilità elettrica
bene quindi abbiamo un team abbiamo un
progetto è fatta quasi stato mancano i
soldi che si fa beh ci perdiamo amica
d'animo ma ci proviamo una bella
presentazione tipo start upper andiamo
individuiamo quelli che potevano essere
degli investitori
in sostanza erano degli imprenditori che
noi credevamo potessero diventare
investitori nel nostro progetto
andiamo li incontriamo e incontriamo
delle persone che sono come noi hanno
più o meno la nostra età erano stati in
qualche modo colpite dal vento tiepido
del caballero e alcuni di essi ce
l'avevano avuto cominciamo la nostra
presentazione tra che vediamo
l'occhietto lucida lacrimuccia ecco il
gioco è fatto
e difatti ci sono cascati
no ci sono cascati una brutta parola ci
ha creduto anche ridotto nel nostro
sogno si è andato fiducia hanno
investito e così è partita la nostra la
nostra avventura partita la nostra
avventura era l'otto novembre 2014
dentro abbiamo trovato sei persone che
avevano il marchio caballero stampato a
fuoco sul cuore
5 pazzi scatenati che saltano a bordo un
milione di fatturato un piano e tutto
sommato anche delle finanze che
bastavano per rilanciare e per mettere
in pratica il nostro piano bene 123
si parte il cominciamo a darci da fare
questo è quello che abbiamo trovato nel
15 luglio 2015 lanciamo le prime due
bici poi rinnoviamo la gamma moto
ampliamo la rete distributiva
il mercato ci dà fiducia e chiudiamo il
2015 con 5 milioni di fatturato i conti
sono quasi in pareggio
a questo punto il mercato ci sta dando
fiducia e vai con un 2016 ritmo
spaventoso facendo che cosa ampliando di
nuovo la gamma delle bici elettriche e
ovviamente cominciando a concepire il
nuovo caballero presentiamo il nuovo
caballero nella fiera più importante di
settore che è milano a novembre 2016 e
nel nostro piccolo è un trionfo 800.000
visitatori ci votano come la seconda
moto più bella del salone wow
incredibile cioè noi siamo assolutamente
alle stelle chiudiamo l'anno con 10
milioni di fatturato con i clienti che
16 dicono questo gli investitori sono
felicissimi aumento di capitale e quindi
il rinnovo della fiducia anche in modo
molto materiale e iniziamo 2017 ancora
più potente nel 2017
ovviamente dobbiamo ingegnerizzare il
caballero perché se è piaciuto questo
punto dobbiamo anche renderlo
costruibile e metterlo in produzione e
ci siamo quasi
cinema quasi a senso che lunedi
comincera il montaggio del primo del
primo lotto e poi ovviamente dopo aver
fatto un mese due anni di incremento
della conoscenza del mercato delle bici
elettriche tiriamo fuori il nostro
gioiellino
a questo punto io vi chiedo un applauso
per il nostro ho giocato lino
[Applauso]
ecco io sono io sono commosso non è come
il papa fuori dalla sala parto che vede
arrivare a rivedere il bambino
sono particolarmente commosso perché è
colui che ci ha aiutato a tirar fuori
abc prima ha detto porca miseria ma è
talmente bella che non sembra neanche
verano
giuro che è vera e stiamo anche vendendo
qualcuno anche la compra e si sarebbe un
ologramma finanziario senza precedenti
ecco ogni curva di questa bici già
dentro una quantità di sudore infinita e
qui abbiamo voluto dare da essere rapiti
follower siamo diventati quelli che
vogliono dire qualcosa nel mercato delle
bici elettrica quindi qui e handling
gripen mai legge il nostro motto quindi
vedete le ruote sono diverse quella
dietro è più piccola un po cicciottella
quella davanti un po più grande e agile
quindi avere grip sul terreno stabilità
ma anche l'agilità di supera gli
ostacoli e la batteria integrata più
grande del mercato in modo che ci si
stufi di andare in bici prima che
lampeggi la famosa ultima spia che da
sempre anziano l'ultima spia di se non
ce la faccio più
però neanche la bici quindi siamo fritti
si torna a casa a piedi o comunque
questo è questa
tutti tra l'altro positivi e lei che lei
che se lo meritano comunque diciamo
anche quest'anno finisce molto bene noi
andremo probabilmente a fare 15 non
viene il numero non vorrei micro che
fosse ecco le nostre forze che portava i
gatti neri che faremo 15 milioni di
fatturato
direi quasi sicuramente ma chiaramente
siamo carichi come delle molle perché
stiamo cominciando a vendere il
caballero adesso a tra parentesi la
settimana scorsa a seconda dei sondaggi
dei vari giornali o dei vari
partecipanti siamo tra il primo e il
quarto posto tra le moto più belle
presentate quest'anno quindi successo
incredibile
questa sembra piacere abbiamo una
quantità di ordini che speriamo di
riuscire a rispettare carichi come delle
molle per fare 25 milioni di fatturato e
poi sognando anche di farne di farne 40
trapani
sì io sono stanco solo a raccontarle la
storia non vi dico
quanta energia si sia voluta per farla
però diciamo ecco a questo punto quello
che mi viene a dire ma sembra fino
adesso una storia di successo poi
poi vedremo però ecco devo dire che
dietro si c'è stato un piano e c'è anche
un team magari anche bravino devo dirlo
perché sono qua io anche quindi sarebbe
stupido se non dicessi il però ecco le
ragioni diciamo secondo me in regione di
successo sono sono più profonde e sono
le regioni del fare ma guarda caso le
ragioni del fare declinate esattamente
come le ha declinato ed ex trento per
questo quando ho visto il bando scritta
immediatamente dico non potete non
prendermi perché è assolutamente così
noi è il la effe di fare
no è certamente esattamente fiducia
perché fiducia nell idea che bisogna
credere in qualcosa e fiducia nel team
noi ce la faremo anche nei momenti in
cui saremo un attimino depressi mia
moglie sa cosa che ascolta qui sa cosa
vuol dire questo e instillare fiducia
negli investitori perché devono credere
in voi
ecco se c'e la fiducia passa via la
stanchezza non c'è non c'è età che tenga
nella nostra carta d'identità c'è
scritto date di nascita tra il 1955 1959
ma è sicuramente un errore di stampa
cioè noi abbiamo vent'anni non c'è modo
di convincersi di qualcosa di diverso
ecco il secondo ingrediente fondamentale
è quello è quello della jir e cioè non
nulla accade accade senza sensazione
cioè i sogni nel cassetto fa
semplicemente la muffa i sogni devono
nascere dalla testa trasformarsi in
pensiero diventare un piano passare
attraverso il sudore o tanto in genere e
poi forse forse alla fine la vostra idea
diventerà un qualcosa di reale però e
dove bisogna fare questo sforzo
altrimenti non succede nulla se
continuano a ripetere le stesse azioni
i risultati saranno sempre gli stessi ma
una cosa non cambiano solo le pubblicità
cambiano da sole e con il l'altro punto
è quello del rischio non si può pensare
di fare qualcosa rimanendo nella proprio
al confort son quindi io sono tranquillo
sono lì seduto e le cose mi succedono
anche questo solo le pubblicità mai
vista una roba del genere bisogna
prendersi dei rischi misurati ma
prendersi lì bisogna andare fuori del
mondo e correre e poi arrivando alla è
quella è valida come le figurine cioè il
primo cosa che ci vuole un entusiasmo
incrollabile indistruttibile per
continuare sempre ad esplorare per
esplorare non è andare in giro con una
cartina e cercare sentiero esplorare e
vedere un bosco e dire secondo me il lì
ci sarà un sentiero significa
percorrerlo dopo tre volte che io
percorri si comincia a vedere sentiero
qualcun altro ti segue diventa una
mulattiera poi altra gente la city 6
e allora diventa una strada e poi lo
chiamano mainstream non facciamo in
stream che prima era un boss che bastano
quindi cioè non ha bisogno
quindi alla faccia dei ministri bisogna
darsi assolutamente da fare
ecco quello che io vi ho raccontato
adesso è la nostra storia il nostro
sogno
ma qual è la vostra storia
quali sono i vostri sogni ecco noi
esseri umani quando caparbiamente
vogliamo qualcosa
siamo sicuramente capaci di fare di
raggiungere degli obiettivi che
razionalmente non sembrano raggiungibili
ecco io vi auguro di essere su questo
palco del teteks o da qualche altra
parte
a raccontare le vostre storie tra due
mesi 2 anni
state sicuri che io sono da qualche
parte nascosto in streaming ad
ascoltarvi orgoglioso magari viene
avervi dato la piccola spallatina finale
per forzarli a fare qualcosa
quindi fate e a questo punto vi auguro
buone storie a tutti
[Applauso]